my name is lena abba
and shireen was my aunt
capitol hill was the latest stop for the
brother niece and nephew of slain al
jazeera reporter shirin abu aklar as
they keep up the pressure on the biden
administration to open an independent
investigation into her killing this is
the very least the biden administration
must do
they cannot rely on israel's word
war criminals cannot investigate their
own crimes chirin was my little sister
the family members also renewed their
call for a meeting with president biden
after he refused during his recent trip
to the occupied territories a u.s
citizen a prominent journalist
beloved by millions of people was killed
by a highly trained israeli soldier
president biden was 10 minutes away he
never came to see us
more than 80 members of congress have
joined the family and calling for an
independent investigation she was trying
to tell us through her journalism what
was happening now we owe her her memory
and her family
an outcome of what happened to her i'm
so sorry to the family and i'm
embarrassed to rest when the murders
wear israeli uniforms there's complete
silence this is bigger than one person
or one country
this is about our values as americans
on tuesday the family met with u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken
afterwards he tweeted that he'd
expressed his deepest condolences and a
commitment to pursue accountability for
shireen's quote tragic killing but the
family said he made no commitment to an
independent investigation the next stop
for the albuquerques will be the
department of justice the family says
it's not naive it's aware of the us's
history of shielding israel from
accountability for its killing of
palestinians or u.s citizens but it says
it has to try and stop the cycle that
leads israeli soldiers to feel that they
can kill at will
shia britancy al-jazeera washington